it's America recycles week and across
the country recycling continues to run
into roadblocks but when a community has
great access to recycling like ours it's
hard to find good reasons not to recycle
Republic Services and our local
governments have been improving access
to recycling they've put single blue
cards in our Valley neighborhoods and
coordinating with garbage pickup days
getting recycling into apartments and
more businesses I spoke to Keith
Harrison she's the CEO of the recycling
partnership a non-profit dedicated to
improving recycling practices about how
we can do more
so when we look at Las Vegas we see
about 90 access rate we see really high
access rate compared to the rest of the
country that means that people have a
good opportunity either at their
apartment or at their home to be able to
recycle now then the second part comes
in on are they sure what to put in the
bin uh this recycling landscape is
always changing things that didn't used
to be recyclable are becoming recyclable
because because Community make leaders
and companies and non-profits like ours
are leaning in hard to make more things
recyclable so we need the public to stay
on their toes and keep in touch with
that so that means education will be an
ongoing exercise to know what's
recyclable and then the last piece is
does it turn into something new so we
put it all into one big bin it goes to a
Murph a material recovery facility to
get separated out so that newspaper is
in one place and cans are in another
only at that point are we able to turn
those things into their next life
well Harrison says we all have to
cooperate to make recycling work
effectively the good news more companies
are looking to turn recycled materials
into new products so we'll be putting a
list of the materials that you can
recycle in southern Nevada if you have
questions it's on our website
8newsnow.com for more information and
you know I talk to people all the time
about Recycling and they say well I'm
not really a good recycler I don't
really know what we're supposed to do
but Republic Services does a really good
job on their website and information on
top of your bin of what can go in and
what shouldn't go in and a lot of times
people just mix their garbage and then
that's all contaminated and it all has
to be thrown away so there's a lot of
controversy around recycling but there's
a lot of good success rates with our
recycling here too so please if you'd
like to recycle it goes a long way you
can it can help